it's et social study your quick catch up
on what the stars are posting online I
love that Kim Kardashian debuted a new
chopped do on snapchat Thursday before
stepping out in Los Angeles she paired
her chic shorter hairstyle with a black
corset top matching skinny jeans and
snakeskin high heels Nick Cannon posted
that incredible clip showing off his
crazy upper-body strength while working
out in the gym taking a look at what
things are like now things are looking
pretty pregnant with Lauren Conrad who
posted this adorable shot of her growing
baby bump on the gram while baby mooning
with husband William Tell joking in the
caption pretending my blended lemonade
is a margarita and pink revealed she's
back in the studio she shared this shot
from inside the recording booth could
this mean new music is coming
[Music]
meanwhile jodie sweetin took to
Instagram to address her recent split
with ex fiance Justin Hodak hosting this
sweet snap with her daughters Beatrix
and Zoey riding in the caption it's
definitely been a roller coaster I'll be
just fine these two little loves are my
everything and we will make it through
[Music]